the local plan we adopted in July 2020
was designed to take us up to 2031.
we're currently working on an updated
version which can be used until 2040.
as part of the local Plan update we have
put out two calls for sites the calls
for sites invited landowners land agents
and other stakeholders to suggest
locations that could be added to the
local plan and given a specific use
potential uses include residential
commercial or Industrial Development as
well as Open Spaces
a number of sites were submitted to us
for consideration
as locations that might be suitable for
specific purposes and Planet District
Council has suggested two sites to be
considered for affordable housing
we're publishing details of all the
sites that have been submitted for
consideration and you can see them on
our website
no decisions have been made about these
sites or their suitability for
development
they're all being reviewed now to see
whether they are actually suitable for
the use suggested
in September 2023 when we know which
sites are deemed suitable for use there
will be a chance for members of the
public to comment and share their views